the desperation is now turning to anger
as families living in freezing
conditions wait for Aid
sky is a special correspondent Alex
Crawford witnessed that rage firsthand
and a warning that her report from the
city of antakia shows attempts to
resuscitate a child who died which
viewers may find distressing
they're using
whatever they can get their hands on to
reach those buried
can anyone hear me she's shouting
they can hear sounds
so they keep calling and listening for
the loved ones who lived here
[Music]
but they've come with little more than
courage and a great deal of Hope
and their tools make barely any impact
on an eight-story building now all on
the ground floor
relatives look on sick with worry
bubbling growing inside
any additional machines to supply our
machines we have no support yet from the
government we have now 40 hours no one
comes nobody nobody are here to touch
this understand from the 40 hour I am
the one waiting here for 40 hours no one
car is game an area here the time now we
are buying here not buying okay just
dying
they stand in huddles weeping and find
Comfort by talking to the trapped
children they may never see again
be strong Denny's she's saying to him be
strong we are here
the fury is real and raw the
government's not here she's shouting
enough enough enough
this city which hugs the Syrian border
appears to be one of the worst hit it's
home to a huge number of Syrian refugees
who fled the war to safety here and the
hatai mayor is from the main opposition
party stoking suspicions that this may
have contributed to the little Aid
evident here
we saw residents helping themselves to
food and supplies from a supermarket
which had been broken into but also saw
a television being carted away
it's because we're hungry one man told
us
desperation is haunting this city
for the love of God please help us she
begs us God I'm waiting for help she
says
her husband's trapped upstairs and
they're flat and has poor sights please
I expect help from my government
so many people who feel they're not
getting the help that they need
not one person he tells us we haven't
seen a single soul here
my daughter's in there with her two kids
another man tells us they've died in
that house
a young baby is pulled out after so many
hours she is a real living miracle
she's too young to remember what
happened but her family will remind her
she's one who beat the odds on turkey's
terrible day of earthquakes
the baby's mother has somehow kept her
alive and she too has been found they're
both badly dehydrated and the young mum
looks traumatized
this has been a terrifying experience
for them all
there are questions about how well
prepared they were here for a disaster
long predicted to happen but every time
someone is coaxed to safety and guided
down the piles of broken concrete which
were once their homes it inspires The
Rescuers to keep on going
but there are far more suffering far too
many mothers consumed by grief as the
wafer than hope they were clinging onto
finally disappears
The Rescuers don't give up though there
are frantic efforts to try to
resuscitate her boy they try and they
keep on trying
this is a young life they cannot save
this region is probably uniquely
ill-equate to cope with a natural
disaster of this scale and the heartache
and grief is going to grow over the next
few days and weeks Alex Crawford Sky
News and antacia Southern turkey